good morning the time being 9:02 we will
get
started we have a quorum with three of
here
so first we'll review the agenda um we
will first get an update on the credit
carry forward liabilities against future
expenses uh from the Department of
Revenue Administration by um Keen Wong
and then we're going to the uh update on
the new investment tax credit the
economic revitalization zone and the
coas County job creation tax credit and
then finally the insurance premium tax
credit then we'll wrap up and set a date
meeting all right so um I guess before
we get started we should just uh um
accept the minutes from last meeting um
move to adopt the minutes as written
presented dick do you want to second
that or I was just taking a scan of this
sure
okay no changes all in favor I I all
adopted okay we'll invite uh Keen Wong
up here to speak on the um credit carry
revenues
start by introducing morning my name is
Keen M Wong tax policy council with the
Department of Revenue good morning my
name is laureno Sullivan I'm the senior
Financial Analyst at the Department of
Revenue
Administration all right um today we
will be discussing the uh the impact of
the credit carryovers um I believe uh
all of your members have a copy of the
calculations that we prepared uh that
was sent over to uh J uh I believe that
was last week so here in front of you is
the uh the our estimate of what in terms
of excuse me terms of the fiscal impact
of the uh the law change that requires
the uh the refund of any excess of five
500% of the uh liability or 250% % or
100 or 100% depending on the tax year
end uh of the credit carryovers so uh
for taxable year taxable period ending
2022 is when it starts uh with the 500%
uh anything in excess of 5% will be
refunded uh and then with tax year 2025
it goes down to 250% and then with uh
tax year
2027 uh taxable perers ending 2027 it'll
be 100% of the excess will be refunded
back to the taxpayers our calculation is
based on using the tax year 2021 tax
return data uh that would be um the
latest um tax year uh that we would have
full data um because of the the the
timing of when returns majority of the
calendar file the returns when they file
their returns um and they will go on
extensions and potentially the the bulk
of the returns calendar your files would
likely file at the end end of the next
year so text your 21 returns calendar
year files they will file on they
following deadlines April 15 of
22 but then um nor normally they will
get an they will file an extension and
file on November 15 of 22 so um so Tex
21 data would be the most complete year
um of text us data and based on this
we've uh our we made our calculations
by delineating the 500% to 50% and 100%
And as an total as a sum the uh amount
of expected carry uh expected refund
would be uh or the amount of the fiscal
impact of that uh of those laws will be
$38.8
million uh with 36.5 million being from
the 500% the 500% uh cut off and then
35.9% % from the uh the 250% cut off
after taking off the 500% and then the
66.4% being at the 100% cut off um after
taking the other previous uh cut
offs um so the table below shows um what
we would expect in terms of a range of
the fiscal impact for the following
fiscal years from 2023 to 2030 uh from a
low let's say if the the the ways where
taxpayers might might if they have a
overpayment how would
they um how would they react to that
overpayment they could either request
for refund or they could either uh
adjust their poten their future
estimated tax payments and utilize that
overpayment in future returns So based
on those data sets we've come up with an
estimate of in terms of a range for each
fiscal year uh between a low and a high
impact um for for each of the fiscal
years for those scenarios and um so
that's what you see in the uh the table
below now
um uh Senator Langs so when you're
looking at the table below right so
again we're dealing with the fact that
taxpayers have a a carryover on the
books um and we have a new law that'll
slowly draw down that tax impact so we
don't keep carrying a liability on the
state side um and give that back to the
business owner or a taxpayer my question
when I'm looking at the 2 million to 23
million is that so I'm assuming you're
talking about 2 million to $23 million
refund or application to a future
liability that they don't send cash in
so it's going to be one of those two
choices correct that's correct and so we
so you're if I look at this to 2 to 23
million so that means that we're going
to to see a negative um impact on state
revenues to the tune of 2 million to 23
million for 2023 either because of the
one of those two cases they took the
refund in whole or they applied it to
their liability for that year and we
didn't see any new money coming in we're
using old money to pay for new taxes
that's
so what's happening in
2030 um it goes down
to
zero that's correct so we get to that
100% in tax year 27 so at that point
what we're seeing on that um tax
expenditure impact would just be uh late
filers from tax year
27 um finally filing the return turns
either taking a refund or using it for
their tax year
28 well actually at that point they have
100% uh yeah Senator l so can you remind
me the years these these these 100% 250
500 go into effect sure so the 500% went
into effect for tax years ending
December 31st 22 the 250 would tax years
ending December 31st 2025 and the 100%
you just just looking at this chart it's
it's interesting because when we look at
2023 to 2025 it's it's heading down now
that cut off being 22 then when we get
to the cut off or in 2025 when it's down
to
the oh I see 2025 CH back up because it
has to do with the timing of how they
file the returns so we went start seeing
any impact until 26 and and a small
impact at that at the 250% but it really
ramps up but then at the same time that
100% kicks in one year earlier so then
you see it kind of balloon when you have
the 100 and the 250 both at the same
time fiscal 20 I think it's fiscal 207
28 really
29 yeah because that that's what I I
think impacted me seeing in 29 such a
huge
increase when I I guess what I'm a
little cons confused about is we had a
250% difference from 22 to
25 um
150% difference between 25 and
27 but yet and and doesn't doesn't this
resolve itself over the course of one
year I mean in one year they have to be
made whole as to the to the law so I
guess I'm I still don't understand how
in 2029 it jumps to
61 sure so there's two things happening
um so in our write up in the middle area
the um the amount of liability at the
100% is nearly double of the liability
at the
250% so um on the tax year 21 example
that we're using of that um what was it
138.0 million 66.4 of that is at the
100% so that's at the back end where
it's only
35.9 at the 250% so that's why you might
see that Whittle down and then the 100
just comes in very strong because
there's just so much more to either to
be refunded
and that's also has a little bit of that
assumption too that if you can leave the
full amount of liability that you will
so that's why we also have that range
because people may just leave 100% now
and they've already fully
conformed okay so I think what you're
saying the the it's shaped like a
pyramid right with that 500% being the
top half of the pyramid not M taxpayers
fall into that there are a few but and
it may be a significant amount but as
you start moving down the two 50 it gets
broader when you get all the way down to
the 100 that's a really broad base lots
of taxpayers carrying slightly over 100
but less than 250 right exactly like we
noticed at the beginning of this um
seeing the refunds go out those who were
hitting the 500% were our smaller
taxpayers because it's just very easy to
hit that 500% Mark if you owe $100 in
tax okay and the return the the refund
if we will on this or the or the
carryover is only anything that's a
above that Mark correct correct right so
we'll maintain going forward 100% right
you can carry 100% credit carry over
every year going forward once we gets
fully matured but if you at 110% you're
going to get a refund for that 10%
correct thank
you and then if if we had projected uh
30 31 uh 20 31 32 33 we don't we expect
that to pretty much be zero to 1.5
million I mean I realize it's going to
change but in that lower yeah area
okay all right
um dick anything
else no I guess the picture is that um
we're going through a
transition which is costly overall to
our
Revenue um but then we'll get to the
other side of it and um Life Will Go On
as they'll pay their liabilities
and yeah I I believe the the initial
concern I believe the initial concern
from the legislators was that we were
keeping a a large balance on the books
and this was a tool to minimize that or
mitigate that
situation
right so is it fair to say we think that
that um idea that the legislature had is
working out uh that we're resolving uh
potential
um sudden Demand on our treasury I think
I think we're seeing that starting to
happen with the refunds um so I guess
yeah it's we're starting to see that
ramp up particularly in this past month
and we'll see it more as on the
extensions come uh the Returns on
extension come in on the calendar filers
and we do have um fiscal filers too so
we'll see some of that impact later in
the year when they come off of extend
ition and file the return and as we look
at your reports we see that in the
refund column is that correct because
those numbers have been up a little bit
I think right now um year to date
through last week when um that those
refunds went out about 30 we identified
about 30% of the refunds were related to
um the taxpayer hitting the CCO C and
some of them opted to keep 500% and
others um a lot more of them are
somewhere between 100 and 500 they're
not just because they can they
necessarily
you okay um next next we're we will hear
about the new investment tax
credit from the Community Development
Finance
handout uh micone there you go thank you
thank you good morning morning I'm Katie
easterly Marte I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Community
Development Finance Authority this
morning I'm honored to be before you to
discuss the new investment tax credit
program which cdfa administers cdfa was
established by the legislature in 1983
to provide Technical and financial
resources to New Hampshire's communities
and Community Economic Development
projects the New Hampshire Community
Development Finance Authority is an
expert in community Economic Development
we have a 40 year history and over $250
million invested and cdfa has impacted
nearly every community in New Hampshire
last year alone we infused almost $30
million into New Hampshire communities
funding 97 community-based projects and
engaging 1222 business donors the tax
credit program is a valuable and unique
State program which incentivizes public
private Partnerships to fund local
community Economic Development the
legislature's goal in establishing the
tax credit was to stimulate private
investment in community projects our
underlying statutory authorization for
the program requires that all tax credit
funded projects must be clearly in the
public interest and its benefits be
publicly available and it contributes to
the economic development of the state
the state tax credit program serves as a
valuable resource for New Hampshire's
communities and has proven success
Community Economic Development projects
across the state supported by the
program range from downtown
revitalization job creation increasing
affordable housing and Recovery Services
the value of the tax credit program
delivers to communities and businesses
throughout New Hampshire far exceeds its
impact on state revenues an independent
analysis of the program concluded that
for every $5 million in tax credits
distributed to projects it directly
generated over $1 million in economic
output created 79 jobs and had auxiliary
Economic Development
benefits I'll explain a little bit about
how the program works cdfa Awards
approximately $5 million in tax credits
annually to nonprofits throughout New
Hampshire allocations made to these
organizations are in the form of tax
credit Equity New Hampshire businesses
support the selected projects by
purchasing tax credits resulting in the
nonprofit receiving a donation and the
company receiving a 75% New Hampshire
state tax credit against that
contribution the credit can be applied
against the business profit tax tax the
business Enterprise tax or the insurance
premium
tax New New Hampshire businesses value
this unique program which incentivizes
and rewards public private Partnerships
to fund local community Economic
Development as a result of participating
in the tax credit program a business's
donation stays in their community and it
helps establish strong relationships
with local
nonprofits for example a business can
make a $10,000 donation for a n cost of
approximately
$1,710 by incentivizing and rewarding
these Partnerships state tax credit
serve as a critical funding resource for
local communities while providing a
unique value proposition to New
Hampshire businesses with a tax credit
donations businesses can direct funds to
a project and lawyer local community
building longstanding
relationships business pledge amounts in
state fiscal year 2023 ranged from $500
to a bit more than
$155,000 from businesses of all sizes in
communities all over the state
furthermore our state fiscal year 20123
da donor data shows that 59% of pledges
received were under
$220,000 35% of pledges received were
between 20,000 and
$65,000 and less than 6% of pledges were
over
$75,000 business donors often include
small local businesses manufacturers
Financial inst institutions insurance
companies and automobile
dealers our Innovative collaborative and
dynamic approach to development Finance
helps our partners make transformative
and sustainable changes cdfa invested in
a total of 97 different projects in
fiscal year
2023 all tax credit projects are subject
to a substantial programmatic and
financial review among other Pro other
requirements projects must provide a
clear public benefit and demonstrate
that similar funding was not otherwise
available as a result of this highly
competitive and rigorous review process
process cdfa tax credit program funds
projects with de demonstrated project
Readiness and viability as well as
deliverable results a few examples of
State fiscal year 2023 tax credit
projects include tax credit investment
to New Ham to the neighbor workor
Southern New Hampshire for a project in
nashaa the funds will support the
creation of 70 of 405 mixed income
affordable housing units right in
downtown nsha the project created M much
needed housing and also contributed to
the revitalization of the
downtown the Boys and Girls Club of
central New Hampshire the Boys and Girls
Club of central New Hampshire used tax
credits to transform the Penacook
Community Center into a 75 uh square
foot 7500 sqare foot child care and
Youth Development Center with an
adjacent Library an auxiliary library of
the city of conquered the project meets
critical Community need by increasing
access to affordable quality child care
and use
Services finally just the last example
from this year and I'd be happy to
answer any other questions about
projects specifically but the farmsteads
of New England in eping they'll use the
tax credit resources to create permanent
Supportive Housing for 27 individuals
with de developmental disabilities the
organization empowers adults with autism
and other developmental disabilities to
live meaningful lives by providing
residential and day services
as evident by our partners the state
investment tax credit program is a vital
and Innovative resource cdfa has has
experienced a significant and steady
rise in demand for the tax credits
year-over-year the demand well exceeds
the current tax credit cap of $5 million
which was established in 1999 cdfa
received 292 applications for Quality
Community Based projects between 2015
and two and 2020 with funding request
totaling $93 million more than double
the $40 million in tax credit Equity
available during that period in addition
100% of the tax credits and have been
allocated and used for decades this tax
credit program is critical Innovative
and it solves New Hampshire's Community
Economic Development challenges thank
you for the opportunity to present the
program to you and I welcome any
questions you
have the uh $5 million cap um first of
all thank you for coming today and
speaking uh the $5 million cap um is
that per organization or is that total
Statewide total
Statewide
okay so the $5 million cap that's the
amount of the credit not the amount you
can collect right because you only give
75 if I remember right 75% of the
donation turns into a tax credit so you
get you're collecting
6.25 potential total donations but it
equals $5 million in tax credit it's
actually we collect $5 million and it
equals U $3.75 million in tax credit so
the maximum liability on the state side
yeah and currently how close are you
sorry if I go ahead so can you talk to
me about how close you are do you get
you hit the $5 million cap every year in
donations single year yep for a decade
and and so every year the state seeing
roughly a
3.75 uh four or five million private
investment we're giving away 3.75
million dollars in tax credits to help
the local communities cor and often um
it's interesting the range of other
funds that the projects bring to bear
for these projects we can be as little
as 5% of the projects sometimes even
smaller amounts but depending on the
financial complexity of the project or
higher amounts if it's a smaller project
um but they're always always bringing
additional funds into the project so for
that $5 million it's leveraging millions
of additional investment as well
right thank you um I have a question so
the boys and girls club for ex for
example um that's a nonprofit correct
yes um and are they actually I guess
what I'm wondering is are they actually
making money to be able to have a tax
credit against oh yeah so they receive
an allocation of the tax credits and
they find businesses who are committed
to that project in Penacook there were a
number of businesses that have been
really challenged their employees were
challenged for many years for child care
and so the businesses really care about
that project that was is being built
right now actually in Penacook and so
they actually make a commitment of a
donation to the project and the business
receives the tax credit oh I see okay
and then the the nonprofit receives the
tax credit Equity to invest in the
construction I see
yeah that's a great project right across
from a a city-owned park and then the
city's committed to creating um a
Auxiliary Library so the city of
conquered has a small Branch that's
actually going to be attached to the
Boys and Girls Club um really making it
a viable Community Center
there
okay representative
B I think that one of your projects is
the Park Theater and uh in Jeffrey it is
yeah been a great success so my question
is actually the other side of that uh
what about failures do you have uh some
projects that just don't make it I can't
think of one wow um projects do
sometimes need flexibility and that's
one of the wonderful things about this
program so for instance a project can
hit environmental issues that they
didn't expect and so one of the sort of
really critical things is that we hold
the resources and provide technical
assistance throughout the period of
Development and Construction and can
really help to resolve any of those
challenges and have the flexibility to
for instance give more time if that's
necessary to complete the project
successfully but we've not had a failure
so we did have one project that had to
pay the resources back but the nice
thing was because of the lean and the
ability to recapture those resources
they were invested right back in the
community okay
um do you have direct staff a
significant staff directly on board to
do this this work uh we have two members
of our staff that are direct on this
program but all of our 14 staff um who
run other programs Community Development
programs really participate in the
Outreach and providing that technical
assistance I think that's one of the
nice things is that we can kind we can
really um have a lot of expertise on our
staff and bring them to Bear where
they're needed on the projects depending
on the challenges or the or what other
uh technical assistance they need to be
successful good thank
you how how is the
cdfa funded we receive administra fees
for um administering the programs that
we do so we also in addition to the tax
credit credit for the state we
administer the Community Development
block grant so that's a program from HUD
and we also administer some private
funds as well all related to community
Economic Development so the state of New
Hampshire is not funding it there's a
very small commitment that needs to be
made by the state in order for the
Community Development block grant to
come um and so we do receive that
thankfully from the state each
$197,000 and that um and the annual
Award of that Housing and Urban
Development Community Development block
grants is a little um a little more than
$9
million and the private donations are
those from businesses and individuals
businesses businesses okay no no
we're just hey thank you and and I I get
the impression that um you think you're
running a very successful program that's
needed yes it's the projects really
speak I think to the success so the the
public private Partnerships that created
by the businesses and the nonprofits is
really I think demonstrated in every
project one of the things that we really
um are always excited about is the
lasting partnership that's created so
the tax credit may be the thing the
vehicle that brings that partnership
together but often the businesses
participate with the project years in
after our investment so they're sitting
on the boards of these nonprofits or
they're providing um uh in service um
cleanup days or working with uh the
youth in the youth program so I think
that the state is really stimulating
that public private partnership that's
beyond the investment of the tax credit
but that's really what kicks it off
that's a good concept we're certainly
seeing that with the Park Theater and uh
the continued engagement of local
businesses in in the work that's
great Senator Lang recommendations do
you have is there anything in the law
that getting in your way to doing more
doing better doing is there any
recommendations you would have for this
committee to how we might adopt a change
to this program to help you better thank
you so much um I think the program is
very flexible and I and we really
appreciate the way that the legislation
was written which really focuses on that
public benefit and ensuring that there's
uh economic outputs I think the only
change would be just an increase to the
tax credit allocation because there's
such a significant demand and there
really is that economic benefit seen by
the investment we would recommend an
increase if that was at all
possible so again so that $5 million cap
you're talking about potentially moving
that up so that you could broaden the
the programs yeah we have demand for
that year after year and because it
really results in that Economic
Development we would ask that the
legislature consider along its other
priorities and uh increase to that $5
million cap do you have a suggested
amount within
reason
uh based on I mean based on how many
people you're seeing applying the the
value you think those projects would
would help the
community I think there could be two
ways of looking at it one of the ways
that we had thought of was actually to
increase the the cost to the state to
the five million so instead of the 5
million of allocation which results in
3.75 I think there's always sort of an
understanding that it actually cost the
five million so if you increased it two
of $5
million um of tax credit that we could
give out then that would be an
allocation of I I think it's 7.2 or so I
think that's a little less than the
demand we actually see so if it was
possible we would really in we would
really see a demand for more like $1
million of allocation of tax credit
resulting in approximately 8.5 of cost
to the
state sure so just to make sure I
understand what you're asking for is the
is have the $5 million reference the tax
credit side yeah and then whatever
revenue on the other side you need to
you can get for donations equal the $5
million in tax credits that's what
you're looking for I think that would be
the minimum I request and then the
maximum if it was feasible would be $10
million uh reference for tax credit
allocation but I think that would that
would be a significant increase and and
really allow us to make a number of
additional
Investments yes repres do you have an
opportunity to make requests like the
budget request Quest like this during
the budget process the state's budget
process are you asked this question we
have Ways and Means well I guess we're
all ways and means but you're something
else in the Senate aren you two things
come on
man U anyway
uh we're not fi the finance committee we
don't do the budget um and uh so I don't
know whether there's some place in that
process that cdfa has an opportunity to
make a request not directly because the
because it's part of statue it doesn't
come up as part of the budget process um
we had there was interest in considering
an increase and um probably two years
ago that was really thought of um but we
were administering an additional 14
million to for uh coid related uh needs
at that time it was the Community
Development block rants coid funds and
so there was just a little less uh sort
of time to be able to really provide the
materials and the information to request
that it would need to come though from
um a legisl a legislative yet an LSR
it's not something that we can that we
can um request okay well it's good to
have this information yeah thank you for
having me makes sense okay thank you
next we're going to talk about the
economic revitalization zone tax credit
and the Coos County job creation tax
credit good morning my name is Chase
Hegman I'm the new director of economic
development at business and economic
Affairs I recently jumped into this role
so my first time before the committee
excited to be here and I'm joined by
brid sorry Bridget Beck I managed the
program welcome so Bridget's our uh
program manager and and expert on these
um particular issues but I thought it
would be helpful to kind of give an
overview of the programs and where they
are um as of this last tax year and then
um answer any questions you might have
either along the way or at the end so
starting with the um economic
revitalization zone tax credit program
it's established oh I'm sorry you also
have a handout and that's largely what
I'll be referencing as we go through oh
this
one it's um yeah it's a few pages just
on the uh programs
themselves so the erz um tax credit
program is established by RSA 162 in uh
it's a short-term business tax credit um
program that focuses on projects that
help improve infrastructure create jobs
and designated areas of municipalities
across the state the state designates
$825,000
a year in available tax credits there
are currently 227 zones across 77
municipalities um and uh the program has
been over subscribed I think 2014 2011
2011 sorry uh the tax credits can be
applied against the business profits tax
and anything uh remaining can then be
applied to um a business's uh business
Enterprise tax the every every cycle the
maximum credit that can be um awarded is
$240,000 with a maximum of $40,000 that
can be applied each year to that
company's
taxes the calculation itself is a
two-part calculation one uh aspect of it
focuses on the uh wage level of new um
full-time positions and the other uh is
an either or um part of the equation
where um the percentage of costs
incurred for infrastructure rure
investment or certain expenditures or a
certain dollar figure based on new job a
new job that was created in that
calendar year and then both of those
parts are added together and it results
in the total amount that they can be
awarded and because the program is over
subscribed there is a prata of
percentage that's applied so that
applicants although may be eligible for
a larger amount are actually awarded
less because so many are interested in
the program and are eligible for it so
this last last uh tax year or calendar
year a prata of 37% was applied for
eligible applicants um $2.2 million in
credits were deemed available uh or
eligible and $825,000 on worth of
credits awarded based on that pretta
that reflects actually about $192
million in uh in investments in the
local economy and projects and 858 jobs
uh there's actually um uh it's it was a
really interesting data point that I
wanted to throw in here um for this last
tax year 94% of the jobs that were
hour yeah and that's the uh erz program
as of right now the Coos County job
creation tax credit ohop sorry go ahead
um let's just um jump in there look at
uh this one that you just talked about
first um the um okay yeah the $18 an
hour I just I was looking to see where
that was okay you do have that on this
sheet
um any questions on what's been
presented so far yes representative Ames
I was
wondering the
um 2022 you get up to uh you jump up to
pretty far above it certainly far more
than twice or almost Thrice the uh
previous year so what's going on there
um so I would I would as a person
processing these say that we had some
larger investments in
2022 postco so the 2020 and the 2021
directly would relate to coid um and
what was going on and and the reduction
in growth at that time and a big gear up
and then you see the the Giant and there
was a couple big hitters we had two uh
that qualified for the max credit and
they had a lot of investment so that's
pretty much where that figure comes
from yes Senator I'm gonna be real
ignorant here explain to me what an
investment means is that like a business
that's going to build a new building and
create some new jobs and there and
they're in the economic zone so
therefore they can apply to the state
for the differential for the new jobs
they're creating based on this
investment they're making in a new
correct just take a moment and look at
sure I'm sorry and we're cap that no
matter what it is it's $825,000 right
now that's the maximum dispersement we
can give that is correct and so we total
up how many new jobs for Lac of phrase
are created within a given economic zone
and then B based on where they fall
within that pro-rated scale are a one
times minimum wage two times three times
whatever that number is um you give a
different ratio back to them for um as a
credit and that tax credit's taken off
the business profits tax business
Enterprise tax where does it go both
both so it starts with the BPT and rolls
into the bet if there's additional if
there's funds remaining on the credit
are they if there's additional so it's
not a double correct double hit
correct
so and um this is sounds like it's
proven to be extremely effective given
you have more applying than you have
total credits
for yeah I I would say and Bridget can
certainly jump in on this um given the
fact that we have ongoing increasing
demand in this program it's regularly
oversubscribed um it's certainly doing
what it was designed to do um in statute
initially um if you ask us if we have
any recommendations I would say we'll
follow up with you because now that I'm
in this role we're reviewing the program
to see if there might be any
recommendations we have as a result of
what we're seeing in it I one more data
request and well just along those lines
um we have to get a report in by
November 1st so um the sooner you can
quick about it that sounds great just a
one data request would it be possible to
get an overlay on the state right a map
and just kind of show a keep map of
where these Investments are being made
made yeah yeah
absolutely we do sorry we do have a list
of the actual eres if you would like to
have that um but I understand you're
asking for where the projects are
effectively yeah basically I want to see
geographically where the where we're
investing this money and what it looks
like I mean the next one's pretty easy
Coos County I pretty much know where
that's going it's all right there but
this one I'd kind of like to see what
the dispersement looks like around the
state likewise the erz as you mentioned
you had a little
those I'm sorry what was that the erz is
that uh the list that oh we have that
for you yeah right oh you got it right
there would you like the list today of
sure I'll do it you it
okay and then I I guess what I'd ask
when you do that that heat map maybe you
can do a second just also overlay the
Coos County so we can see how these two
interact with each otheres that make
sense so the heat map will contain both
the erz credit as well as the Coos
County Credit maybe in different colors
so we can see where the map looks oh
absolutely sure may I ask a clarifying
question if we don't have the actual
ability to make a map would a a a
listing of of locations suffice sure I
can create a map out of that so we can
probably do it I just want to make
sure show you a piece of software that
good
okay I guess um at this point we can
County uh the Coos County job creation
tax credit under RSA 77e and
162q um provides qualifying companies
with a tax credit for every new
full-time yearround employee hired in
Coos County it can be renewed for the
credit itself can be renewed for up to
five consecutive tax periods if the
employee that was hired remains um with
the employer there's no limit on this
program uh like the um erz so there's
not a Set Max on how much can go out in
terms of tax credits but uh there
although there has been um increasing
Demand on the program over the last
several years it seems to be hovering
between 187,000 and
$225,000 a year uh in terms of credits
that are going out the door to qualify
there are two levels of tax credit in
the program one is $750 one is
$1,000 um per qualified worker and
that's based off where their wage Falls
relative to the um State minimum wage so
you get a $750 tax credit if you um hire
someone um equal to or greater uh than
150% of the current state minimum wage
uh then you get $1,000 credit if it's
200% or greater of the state minimum
wage in 2022 uh credits totaling
$222,200 we approved representing 225
jobs and 39 businesses in Coos County
across service retail manufacturing uh
and Professional Service sectors that uh
reflects a breakdown of 78 new positions
and 147 that were retained or renewed
based on that ongoing fiveyear
period anything else you want to add
Bridget uh just much like the other
program as we can see the the 92%
they're paying a higher wage up there so
end so there's no no cap on this as you
mentioned so this is something that I
guess we just have to it looks like it's
fairly constrained um so there's no need
to take any action unless this suddenly
jumps uh out of control but right now it
seems fairly
stable so again I understand it this
$750 per newe job
is the credit that the business would
receive again bet BBT um application and
they're allowed to renew a new job up to
five years so if I create a from in job
in year one um then I get one credit if
I create another new job I get a credit
for the first job and the second job and
and it it Cascades down up to five years
and at the end of five years that first
one will fall off and they're back to
just whatever new job they create asked
correct repr aims so I guess the theory
the idea is that
um that with this tax credit will
enable companies to
employ a person or persons where they
wouldn't
otherwise have been able to do that it's
it's sort of that additional boost the
ideas um that this uh program provides
do you have any way of testing whether
that's what's happening
or worst case companies are just getting
$1,000 or whatever it is um and um
that's nice but they would have done it
anyway I think that's a difficult
question to answer actually um and I'm
not even sure they could answer that um
I'm I'm sure they all do appreciate
getting the credit and I'm sure they're
reinvesting it back into the business
but
um whether they would have hired if this
credit had hadn't been there it would be
really hard to get that answer I think I
bet it's a good question I agree I don't
I don't to to answer it directly I don't
think we have a specific data point on
whether they would or would not have
done something based on the credit but
it's certainly incentivizing the
behavior that is desired by the statute
you know hiring and retaining a
Workforce in in a very rural County um
where that Workforce is needed yeah
thank
you I'd have to agree I'm looking at
just your numbers again it looks like
the North country is seeing a little bit
of job growth at least relative to the
tax credit so which is what the intended
I think the intended purpose of the
credit was to begin with was to help the
jobs anything
you okay now we will hear about the
insurance premium tax credit um please
introduce yourselves hello and good
morning uh thank you for having us here
today my name is Christy rice I am the
assistant commissioner of the New
Hampshire insurance department
accompanied by me today is Amy duim our
chief tax officer we're here to review
the tax credits that are allowed on the
New Hampshire insurance premium tax
returns and the financial impact of
these credits in fiscal year 2023 we
generated approximately
123.5 million in premium taxes from the
licensed insurers
licensed insurance companies with a net
of $1 million that was transferred to
DHHS in the form of the Granite State
Advantage
transfer the total credits taken on the
premium tax returns were $3.7 million
which is about 3% of the premium taxes
collected or 2.4 of the insurance
Department's total net revenue this is
not part of the slideshow it's just an
introduction if you're
looking
um I'm sorry yes 98.5% of the 3 $2.7
million in credits taken are a direct
impact of licensed insurance
companies that have filed a business
Enterprise tax return with the
Department of Revenue Administration in
fact there's only three credits that a
company that companies are allowed to
take on their premium tax returns if
qualified and that is a business
Enterprise tax Community Development
Finance Authority contribution and the
life and health insurance guarantee fund
assessment um Amy will review the handes
handouts that you have in front of you
for further detail and then we'll be
happy to answer any questions questions
that you might
have great thank you good morning today
we'll begin with the first slide here uh
to review the credits for the business
Enterprise taxes filed with the
Department of Revenue or bet as we often
refer to it uh the bet is imposed under
RSA 77e and is allowed as a credit
against the premium taxes due under RSA
400a when a New Hampshire licensed
Insurance Company claims this credit on
their premium tax report they must Pro
provide the proper documentation which
would be a copy of their prior Year's
bet return any credit amount in excess
of their premium tax liability can be
applied to the company's business
profits tax filed with the Department of
Revenue therefore there's no carry
forwards of these credits to subsequent
premium tax
returns you'll see in the last four
years the credits taken have ranged
between 2.8 million and roughly 3.7
Million last fiscal year 141 companies
took this credit and where we collected
close to 1,300 premium tax returns this
accounts for close to 11% of the
credit on the next you'll see a
flowchart illustrating how this bet
credit is applied so first when the
insurance company files and pays their
business Enterprise tax with the
Department of
Revenue and then they submit their
premium tax filing with us they are
reporting their prior year bet payment
as a credit against their current year's
tax
liability we then review the company's
prior year bet return and ensure that we
have the proper supporting
documentation once we've audited did all
the BET credits taken we then forward a
copy of a report to the Department of
Revenue listing all these credits and in
2021 RSA 21 j14 was amended and anou was
put in place between the Department of
Revenue and the New Hampshire insurance
department which allowed for base uh
better sharing of information between
the two
agencies after Department of Revenue has
had a chance to to review the file we
sent them containing the tax credits
they in turn return a report to us
verifying the amounts that each company
took as a
office next we have credits taken under
RSA 162 L10 for contributions made to
the Community Development Finance
Authority or
cdfa and as you've just heard an invest
M credit equal to 75% of the
contribution made to the authority
during the tax years allowed against
their tax liability under RSA
400a contributions received by The
Authority which qualify for the credit
shall not exceed 5 million in any state
fiscal year tax credits are allowed
either individually or in combination
against the insurance premium taxes
business profit taxes taxes or business
Enterprise
taxes on the annual premium tax
statement the New Hampshire licensed
insurance company reports and provides
documentation of the contributions paid
during the calendar year Credit in
excess of the premium tax liability can
be carried forward up to 5 years and
cannot exceed 1 million in any given tax
year the next slide depicts a flowchart
of these credits taken so once the
insurance company makes the donation
they receive a letter back that from the
cdfa thanking them for their
contribution and verifying their tax
credit
eligibility the company then reports the
tax credit on their premium tax return
and provides us a copy of the letter for
supporting
documentation on page six you can see
the impact these credits have had on the
insurance
department now all the the community
Finance development Finance Authority
supports projects across the state and
there's numerous projects as you've
heard that they're involved with the
group of insurance companies taking the
credit over the past four years were
targeted towards the projects that I've
listed
here and you'll see that over the last
four years that for three of those years
we only had one company making a
contribution and taking the credit and
in fiscal year 2022 there were three
companies that made a donation all of
Group and the last credit that is
allowed against the premium tax returns
are in accordance with RSA 408
B13 which are credits for assessments
paid to the New Hampshire life and
health insurance guarantee
Association this Association is composed
of member insurers licensed to sell life
and health insurance along with annuity
contracts in the state of New Hampshire
in the inent in the event that a member
insure is found to be insolvent and is
ordered liquidated by a court the
association will provide protection up
to certain limits to New New Hampshire
Insurance consumers who are holders or
beneficiaries of covered policies in
annuity contract tax with the insolvent
insurer a member insur May offset
against their tax liability under RSA
400a any Class B assessment described in
RSA 408 B9 2B for the life insurance and
annuity account and for the health
account for guaranteeing the performance
of contractual obligations of an
impaired or insolvent insurer in regard
to disability income coverages
only so in short that's basically life
insurance annuities and disability
income lines of
business the credit is allocated at 20%
of the assessment for each of the five
calendar years following the year in
which the assessment was paid there have
not been any of these credits taken in
the last four years the last assessment
that was assessed that qualified for a
tax credit was issued in
2013 therefore the first year the
companies took this credit was on their
2014 tax return which is actually filed
in
2015 and since this credit is allocated
over five years the last of these
credits were on the calendar year 2018
tax return filed in
2019 so just so you have an idea of the
impact these credits have had in
previous years in fiscal year 2019 there
were 181 companies that took this credit
amounting to
376,000 and this was about the average
amount that had been taken each year
2015 and lastly we have a flowchart of
what we just reviewed where the
association will issue a Class B
assessment for the life annuity or
disability income claims file by the
policy holders of the
insolvent in uh insolvent member
insurance
company we will verify with the
association each year whether any
assessments were levied that qualified
for the tax credit and the insurance
company would pay their assessment
invoice and Report the amount of the
qualified credit on their tax return
also providing a copy of their invoice
as supporting
documentation so that's a recap and the
impact of the three credit credits that
can be taken on the insurance company's
premium tax reports and can I clarify
anything or answer
questions uh thank you for that
presentation um the on page
seven I'm a little confused on that
because on bullet point three you say
the last assessment which qualified for
tax credit was issued in
2013 but then on the next bullet it says
FY 2019 there were 181 companies that
took the credit yep because that is
allocated over 5 years 20% for 5 years
so the very last from the from the
assessment issued in
2013 the last time it was on their tax
return was 19 okay so why why is no one
taking this credit
anymore um it's very specific to the
lines of business that I mentioned the
life insurance the disability income and
the annuities not not every Health
insurer but the
member uh insurance companies if they
were to go insolvent they have to write
just these lines of business so there
have been other companies put in
Rehabilitation or liquidated but they
just didn't write the New Hampshire
business for those lines I see so these
insolvency question I'm I'm gonna go
back to page two okay um I just want to
make sure I'm clear enough so it lenses
insurance companies and people providing
Insurance products pay the uh insurance
premium tax and what this slide says is
that they're allowed to deduct from
whatever their tax total obligation is
based on the premiums they've they've
collected they're allowed to deduct the
any bet tax that they paid from their
premium tax bill La of better raas and
the net of that is what the agency
collects right so they can't take a
credit of more than their tax liability
and anything left over can be applied
against their business profits
tax with the Department of Revenue so if
they I'm sorry so again I'm trying to
understand a little bit so if the
premium tax that they owe and then they
subtract out the BET and if they still
have more like the tax was less than uh
the or I should say the tax is more than
the bet they can then take it forward to
the BPT I'm sorry say again I'm I'm
trying to understand exactly how that
cash flow happen
um so if their tax liability were
100,000 let's say and their bet was
50,000 they're still going to owe us
50,000 okay and if they're some crazy
reason their tax liability was 50,000
but they paid 100,000 in bet what
happens to the other 50 is that just is
they can apply it against their business
profits tax so we'll send a report of
the credits taken on the the premium tax
rate returns we'll send a report to the
Department of Revenue letting them know
what was taken okay
yeah now does is there a Max on this for
the at the state level or is it just for
the
BET
um no um well I guess the max would be
the absolute Max would be a company's
bet and
BPT uh just the business Enterprise tax
so the business nothing to do with the
business profits tax can be taken as a
credit on the tax return I thought you
just said that if if it's greater than
the BET then you can apply to the BPT
the the leftover bet credit can be
applied against the business profits
tax right which could potentially for
some companies wipe out their bet and
BPT depending on the size of the credit
the BET could wipe about the BPT is that
what you're saying yeah um that would
here the well I'm just going back to
what Senator Lang asked so if the credit
is larger than the BET owed you said
then the balance could be applied
against the BPT correct so I'm just
saying there may be some instances where
a company May wipe out both there bet
and BPT I suppose yeah that's a
potential probably not likely year
because then they're going to Wi out of
business
so
you
questions um and so in general um does
this seem like an effective program or
are there issues that you see that
should be
solved um no we haven't since I've been
there we haven't had the the life and
health assessment credits taken um
currently only one with the
cdfa
um yeah we don't for us it's more about
information sharing okay yeah yeah so at
this point you wouldn't recom anything
be changed about
this no okay
time sounds good it's sounds like your
uh interface with Dr has improved with
maybe as a result of better technology
better software and so forth yes
definitely
yeah all right thank you very much for
coming thank you so much have a great
you
all right we are on wrap up now we've
heard all the
presentations thank you all for
coming um I guess we need to talk about
next steps here because um we do have a
report that is due on November
1st um
and I guess this commission continues or
not commission joint committee continues
past that point um I guess what we we've
reviewed the five areas that we wanted
to
uh for this for this report which was
the new investment tax credit the
economic
revitalization uh the Coos job County uh
job creation um the insurance premium
tax credit and the um
credit carry forward so we've done those
we've done those five now um what do we
see as next steps so my recommendation
Mr chair is why don't we walk through
those five see what our recommendations
are for those five I can then draft the
our report that be great um for us what
it might look like based on our
recommendations after the review um and
then next meeting we can potentially
look at voting on that what what were
the five cdfa erz Coos County insurance
premium tax credit and the credit carry
forward
liabilities okay if you look at the
agenda from today you yeah easy SAR see
prior tax expenditure committee report
that Patrick abramy
did um identified the children's
scholarship fund as a program that had
been incompletely reviewed and it was
listed as a program that needed to be
reviewed so I I and it's too we're not
going to do that before November one
okay excuse me um but I think I'd like
to see flagged in the report you draft
that we're going to look at that um in
this coming
year and that was called what the child
the child scholarship children that's
the that's the EFA and um low income
scholarship program that we education
tax credit programs is technically what
it's
called does that make sense to you so
the I so the recommendation on that
would just be that in the next meeting
that whoever takes up this manle which
be us again I don't know if it's due
next year I think it's us if it's an
every year thing it's an every year
thing yeah so next year November number
one we've got to write another one yeah
and so we'll just say that we our point
is to take that one up let's commit to
do it doing it it's obviously a big
program it's also a controversial
program as we all know um and so it
merits uh uh a careful look so
recommendations on the five right so
cdfa are we going to take up their Rec
their request of increasing the actual
available credits up to $5 million with
a total investment of
7.2 is our recommendation to do that do
we think that's in best interest of
communities in the state um or do we
just make no recommendation and that the
current program is working well and
serving our communities that's a good
question it's clearly a very good
program right and uh I think each of us
has has seen it play out um I know I
have um in a good way and uh um it's
clearly um unable to fully meet the
um presumably do as well with some
increment as it's done thus far and uh
so the only question is sort of
budgeting and I think you put it into
the hopper so I would I guess I would
endorse uh the
modest increment that uh well is it 50%
increment I guess so it's pretty big or
30% something like that yeah on the
investment side it'll be a little over
be like 40% right going from 5 to seven
yeah right so roughly 40% increase in in
available Investments with a
corresponding credit increase to go with
it I think what they would like would be
to go to $10 million um one of these
components um but but what sort of made
sense in terms of numbers that are being
batted about was go up to $5 million for
the tax credit which means the money
they get is that much greater goes to 7
million something right yeah I think
that incremental change makes sense and
then you know it'll get reviewed again
to see um is it you know how's it doing
should it be increased further yeah um I
think they would love it if we doubled
it but I think U exactly going to the
seven I think this a good good step and
uh how does how does this work so we
make this recommendation who are we
making it too I mean is again some's got
to pick it up yeah someone's someone's
got to decide to put a bill in right but
we're past filing periods right so it's
kind of an irrelevant for this year um
but it doesn't mean that next next term
that someone will pick it up right yeah
so somebody could just look or somebody
could amend a bill somehow and put it in
but it would be it would be sitting
there in our report as something that
somebody could point to and use okay if
I remember right the report goes
to you know all the typical people right
the speaker the president the clerk um
the Senate Clerk and Governor yeah so
all right so cdfa I think we're we're
going to say it's working well the
communities in the state are being well
served by the by the uh by the credit
and that our recommendation is to
increase the available tax credit up to
the full $5 million allowing donations
to incre increase accordingly yeah right
yep we good with that yeah but I guess
we have to state that it's we have to
set a number like 7 million is the new
yeah 7.2 they indicated so allow tax
credits up to $5 million which would
increase donations up to $7.2 million
right y just a matter ofe the the number
that's specified in the statute is the
tax credit number or do they have that
well that's why I asked that question
it's Their donation cap so we increased
the donation cap to 7.2 which will
result in $5 million in tax credits
right got it and is the state so what is
the state giving oh no it's a tax credit
I'm sorry it's a credit so a business
again private businesses donate to um
the organization and they're able to
take that off their business profits tax
as as a charitable donation means that
the
state effectively gets get 75% $1
something million Less in terms of
Revenue okay yeah no that sounds good
okay second one was um the
erz right so on the erz we just heard
that
today again over sub subscribe program
if I remember right yeah I think that's
right um it's a cap at 825,000
um people are getting only 37
.4%
alone I think I agree what's up I think
I agree I mean look look at how it's
decreasing though so so
pration right the pration decreases
because of the investment increasing
right so again this is the one where
um someone let me make sure although
what's interesting is in 2019 2.4
million was requested so at 2022 we
still were less than that Max yeah maybe
we do just leave it for
now remember the
yeah I mean obviously it's still over
subscribed it was oversubscribed in
um so my my toughest point on this
conversation is I don't know how much
$750 moves the needle for an employer
whether he's going to add a position or
not it gets to my my question yeah I
mean I just don't know that it's really
an effective tool right for the money it
is I mean I know as when I was an
employer and 22 employees I don't know
that I would have hired somebody just
because someone's going to give me an
extra
$750 to put on a $40,000 $50,000 job
right so I don't know that it's there's
a great um while there's increased
demand for it I don't know that there's
Great Value that's a good point I
wouldn't want to lose it but I wouldn't
want to add to it either yeah because
why wouldn't there be demand I mean if
somebody can take it they'll take it but
I think to your point they're already
planning on hiring something right yeah
yeah I mean I'll be honest one those
maybe something that sort of adds to the
buzz around uh um an area that the
community wants to stimulate and
encourage development and so this is one
of those things that is an incentive to
that creates a buzz around doing that
but I don't know that's just a guess to
me this is okay this is sort of like the
ER R&D tax corre
I don't know that it creates any new
jobs that's another one that's very
small yeah right but it but it's a check
box one thing I've heard Ways and Means
and all the years in the house was
there's always a check boox do you have
an R&D tax credit yes we do and I check
the box off and it makes the state
attractive to somebody because we have a
credit that's what I meant by Buzz you
know the same so I I my my
and so I'm just going to put in a report
it's working it's over subscribed but
there's no recommendation for changing
exactly should we say we don't believe
it's going to um result in increased
hiring or I I don't think we jump into
the deep end of that pool right because
that becomes a political argument we're
just going to make no recommendation to
change okay that's my opinion yeah no
you're probably right because as soon as
we once you say it's not creating jobs
and people starts another fight right so
yeah all right so next was was um the
Coos County job creation
credit the same discussion
really just one
County but it is a poor
County well there's no limits on that
one so it's true there's really nothing
to change right now the only time we
would change that would be to put a
limit because it's yeah if it was being
over if we were paying a huge amount you
know a huge i' leave it be yeah so we
next one is this insurance premium tax
credit just a logical thing I don't I
don't really understand the last piece
that she was talking about so that's
tring so if you remember right I was
trying to remember this so insurance
companies pay I I don't think it's any
different than businesses right a normal
business but it's weird and that the
insurance companies pay the insurance
premium tax credit and they're allowed
to D doct the BET their payroll tax from
their liability on the tax credit right
um because they're already paying you
know it's kind of a weird mix right so I
don't quite get it myself but um I don't
know that we have a reason to change it
right I definitely leave it be it's sort
of uh it's sort of like avoiding double
taxation I that's the idea that's the
way I looked at
it and and to my the answer to my
question about what changes recommend
they said none so I think given that we
don't feel any and they aren't asking
for any yeah so the last one is the big
one the credit carryover yeah right and
the big numbers and big budget impact
for recommendation
um no I guess my concern is I was I was
almost questioning whether we should
spread that out a little further to
lessen the impact to the state as a
recommendation instead of getting hit so
hard so fast interesting question yeah
or whether we leave it just it is and
take the hit you know what you could do
is um flag it um say that
uh
we we're concerned about the impact of
um uh we'll we'll be reviewing that and
making recommendations on it during this
next year
because we can't do that right now you
know I don't think we know no question
is whether we recommend it for somebody
else to pick up next year right because
the next impact is 2027 yeah right
that's when is that well
2025 I don't know how that review is
going to happen I guess a Ways and Means
Committee would look at it yeah I mean
or maybe we could recommend the Dr
um identify options that
might might uh spread out the impact is
that what we're talking about yeah
spreading out the impact so it doesn't
hit the budget so hard so we could
recommend that yeah that's I was that's
was my suggestion was whether I I my
recommendation would be to do that right
because you're taking a pretty hefty hit
especially when you get that at 100%
right is that we're taking a $61 million
hit to the budget potentially and
remember that this is also any taxpayer
can always request a refund at any time
of their credit so this is a forced
refund that we're requiring
so um so all we're saying is we're not
going to force the refund process we'd
make a recommendation we spread that
forced refund out a little further to
lesson to to create a Glide slope rather
than a cliff for the T for the budget so
my recommendation would be that Dr
undertake a review of this and
make and identify legislation that would
be needed to spread out the impact in a
reasonable way I don't know something
like that is that is that the idea yeah
yeah and I'm most concerned from 2026 if
I look at this table 2026 and on because
you can see 22 million 33 on the high
side 22 million 33 million 41 million 61
million we can probably absorb 2024 we
have a a a decent rainy day fund right
now I mean I think if that gets bigger
than we think um I'm not too worried
about 23 you know 23 and 24 are likely
to be much at
the closer to the leftand side number
the low number than right yeah right
hand side number although because we
don't know so why am I saying that I
don't well yeah we don't know but but it
looks like it the worrisome time starts
from 2026 yeah I hear you so I'm like I
I was just breaking it up into fums
right budget when budgets are going to
hit right so you're looking at 27 and 28
right even on the low side we're looking
at a $23 million tax hit at the low side
in that in that banum to a $74 million
hit on the high side so you know some
significant dollars for a budget hit and
so again maybe spreading that out you
know jumping from going from 250 maybe
we we change it to a you know 50%
decrement for a few de bi enums to get
down to 100% rather than um a full 250
straight to 100 so uh this would be a
report to uh the uh two- ways of means
committees and finance committees yeah
well and it goes to the
there's a whole L the speaker and so
forth that too would make sure they get
committees I once and the the nice thing
is once we get to 250 which we will in
25 at least we're we're we're halfway
there I 500 that's the other point with
the this overhang that people worry
about has been less the risk is is
diminished right 500 is is huge if that
you know suddenly hit all at once
so so the recommendation committee is
there concern about the starting in 2025
the fiscal impact to the state on such a
uh dramatic change and consider have Dr
and to in legislature consider expanding
that law to go for a longer time period
at a smaller reduction yeah to ease the
impact on the budget yeah and should we
suggest Poss 50 basis point um you know
250 to 200 to 150 right do it over each
bium until get done I wish make a
suggestion is okay so the suggestion is
um 50% reduction going from 250 to 200
and 1 bym and then go from 200 to 150
and the next BM and then down to 100% in
the third so it spreads it out over six
years rather than over two sounds good
yeah
would it making legislation were that
this easy what's that would it making
legislation in fact were this easy yeah
anything else yes so what we what two
things one is um you just said once you
write the report we need a meeting to
approve it I think we don't need a
meeting we can do we just sign off on it
if everybody we sign off the problem is
if we want changes to it we got to be
careful about sending emails around
because then we start dealing with 91a
issues that's a good
right so um I can write it and draft it
and then you can determine if we need a
meeting um individually you can each
send me as long as you don't include the
whole team I think that's right we can
do it that way yeah individually you can
say Tim I'd like to amend this and then
I can make the Amendments and adjust
should be able to pull this off unless
you really mess up and give
us I mean the two that aren't here I I
don't know that they're going to have
any major oh yeah we have three of them
we have no recommendations where systems
great yeah right so there's no
recommendations we only have
recommendation on cdfa and credit carry
over yeah um so right I mean because
I'll talk to Lou so okay the other thing
I'm looking at is just uh time you know
just time left right for the November so
to make sure so today's the 20th um we
would have to have a
meeting you have to submit it on the
first is that has to be signed and
submitted by the first again I'll write
it up and then we'll see where it goes
only I'll ask I I'll blind copy
everybody so that anybody has a reply
all we don't get the whole committee um
right and I'll just blind copy everybody
and then I'll just s ask for suggestions
and changes and then I'll adapt and if I
ruin school with it I'll get it typed up
and sent for everyone's signature and
maybe each of you need you need to
process with um FR yeah and I'll talk to
l l so that we minimize any yeah yeah
potential ises
okay I don't think there'll be any
problem but no because we don't have
time and my to my point is today's the
20th if by I don't know the 25th or 26th
we I'll try to have to by Monday right
so you can start that process of editing
now we don't have to actually this
doesn't have to go into the calendar if
we have another meeting it doesn't have
to go on the counter because it's a
joint it's a joint yeah still has to
committee well there was something weird
where when I scheduled I forget what it
was the fir this is our second meeting
when I scheduled the first one it didn't
go in the calendar and Jennifer said it
doesn't have to it's a joint it's a
joint committee so that's weird yeah so
in theory if we had to we could you know
but if I'm remembering that correctly
I'm pretty sure that's what one way or
the other we can have that meeting if we
have I'll draft it afid a signature
sheet you just got to show up at
somewhere in sign whatever office I can
leave it my office my secretary just pop
in and sign off everybody signature
that's a v a yes vote to the ring well
we're all going to be around next week
on Thursday right I'm be here Wednesday
veto day right oh yeah we're gonna be
here on 26 V yeah so I'll have it by
then I'll I'll get it out to you by the
by Monday the draft report request your
input for changes um and then I'll bring
it the 26th so
sounds good we need to set date for
another
meeting what because what's our next
it's just to vote Yes but like I said I
think we can just do that with your no
but you're talking about next year the
the next 12 months I I suggest we try to
do something in
January um possibly February but uh and
I I'd suggest do the CH children's
all right so we don't we we can just
email back and forth kind of set a DAT
for that next meeting I think again J I
know that so busy they're pushing us to
like we want I don't know how we're
going to do it but they want bills heard
the first week of January like we
haven't introduced him yet technically
how do we schedule hearing but they're
getting us to try to jump because we
know what we're going to be do you guys
are going to th
bills you have 800 plus plus 200 rained
rained you guys have ton of and we're
going to get stuck with all those I
don't know how many of those 220
retained on January the first meeting in
January going be sent to the Senate and
we're going to have to deal with what
happens when we pass house bills how do
they
go so are you talking about um well just
in general so we have well we have the
same process you do right so once you
send us a b can we scheduled public
hearing we have everything else that's
right so we still but the the only
question we're gonna have is like so so
112 is a good good example senville 112
we've already passed it right I was just
asking I I don't remember ever having
Committee of conferences in the second
year but apparently you
must right so you're gonna on January
whatever day we meet you're gonna vote
on 112 right all of the retained bills
if it's a Senate bill it means it's got
to come back for concurrence or a non-c
concurrence right if it's a house bill
we'll just take up our first public
hearing on it right and treat it as a
new bill um like like a second year
crossover bill or first year crossover
bill so um so that's all I know that
they're asking us to like the chairs so
like I want you to have meetings first
week second week in January like
I we haven't adopted the bills yet till
the first meeting when we accept the
bills of the of the legislature how do I
schedule a meeting before we've accept
it
but yeah so I don't know what what you
guys are doing on your side but I know
that on our side there yeah it's going
to be it's going to be busy um how busy
it's going these out early and get them
done because we don't know the end of
yeah I know they're already pushing on
the other end of town to have a
longer yeah we got told that jeet's
have
talking first
second and maybe moving across so you
we it
is well I'll get this out to you guys by
Monday and then I'll send you back
comments make you that JS after I've
heard from everybody and then um if
everyone's cool I'll a
over at
um over at
L I'll let you know where
it uh first floor of the State House by
the back door so if you walk in the
state house all the flags yeah 107 so if
you're walk in the Hall of flags on the
front door it's on the left hand side
last
off in the back by the back door
out not allow
just
well
no well this guy was yelling at Jeb
because Jeb Jeb was like gave all my
name to every state agency said oh you
need a bill go see Tim and he sent him
all by way I must have like eight agency
just Department
some
andar birthday today so I'm swear
louder
and let me know if you anything on that
I will be back to you yeah has a copy of
so paste and change what you want you
the drafting attorney uh
okay
oh Monday if you've got to be here
slump is
here it is an absolute gonna be a
disaster something that metal detectors
so be packed you bated early what metal
detectors set up they're going to have
that